[Music]
what's going on guys
2018 is upon us and I have it on good
authority that movies will be released
this year a lot of them today we're
gonna talk about what's coming out and
what we're looking forward to and we got
a couple of prime movie minds to talk
about it with she's making her debut on
the screen junkies show she's one of the
hosts on see it or skip it on Rotten
Tomatoes and a writer at black girl
nerds welcome Jacqueline Coley so glad
to be here and this man you know him
from Access Hollywood and he's my
biological father
Scott man's 2018 is upon us father and
son reunited yes right and by the way if
my mom is watching it's just a joke mom
don't worry okay let's start off with
the superhero movies okay Marvel is what
12 films in Marvel my son is 17 movies
in for this Marvel Cinematic Universe
Wow up to four Ragnarok yeah 18 is my
number one highly anticipated film for
2008 which is black pants yes yes the
best gift that we're gonna get during
Black History Month February cannot come
let me tell you yeah I'm really excited
about this one man I mean Chadwick
Boseman that guy is like what a career
he's having like he plays Thurgood
Marshall Jackie Robinson James Brown
James Brown and King to chala yeah the
reason Black Panther is really gonna be
great it's look who's directing the film
ryan coogler did Creed a Fruitvale
station and whenever Marvel the Marvel
Cinematic Universe cuz you know they
have the other films like from Fox and
Sony so we're talking about the MCU here
they've taken a lot of chances with
directors and they've always paid off
what about the Deadpool sequel
Pulis another example of a movie in the
chambre itself that can change the game
was clever it was smart
it was imaginative yeah really it was
basically a spoof of superhero yes but
the problem is that the director of did
the first step pool is not doing a
sequel this is the thing I heard and
this is rumor innuendo conjecture that
the reason why they went and recast the
director was not because of a vision
issue it was because of a budget issue
like they wanted to keep it that run and
gun like work off a smaller budget get
creative and he's like hey I did that
already it was a lot of hard work give
me my money and Locke's couldn't afford
to do it one and didn't want to do it
too and so they said no so I'm actually
interested to see like this one you know
Ryan Reynolds has been very clear that
he wants to keep that same vibe going
yeah if the marketing is any indication
they are so on it okay before we seg
away from Marvel one of their crown
jewels after black panther working their
way up to Avengers infinity war and the
great thing about Avengers infinity war
its threat to buy the Russo brothers yes
who what they did with Captain America
the Winter Soldier but Winter Soldier if
he asked me and maybe you is the best
movie in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
it was better than Avengers the thing
that worries me about Avengers infinity
war yeah is they're just from the
trailers from the footage we've seen
they're really putting everything but
the kitchen sink into this film I mean
how long is this movie you're gonna have
like members of the guardians of the
galaxy in a - spider-man in it but we've
doubted them before we doubted them with
Avengers they pulled it off we doubted
them with civil war they pulled it off
so they haven't given us any reason to
really say no that's gonna be overcrowd
your right let's talk about Aquaman yeah
and don't be wrong Jason I love you babe
I'm so ready to see you shirtless with
wet hair all the things sorry to
objectify you but it's the truth it's
gonna be real on this one yeah but I'm
really worried for the film because
after Justice League we were 1 for like
7 this is gonna be a telltale moment if
Aquaman doesn't make it I would look
really quickly for a hard
reboot on everything that the DCU yeah
that's a good point they really have to
take a step back of Warner Brothers in
DC and be like okay what are we doing
wrong here wreck-it Ralph to any any
thoughts looking forward to that at all
you know wreck of Ralph's was a pleasant
surprise yeah and it's interesting
because it sort of feels like right at
home coming out the same year as ready
player one yeah it sounds like these two
movies could be like a double feature
feel like this is gonna subvert internet
culture a lot and really just talk about
how funny that is and I'm really excited
to see what they do with it I hope it
does well and there's a Cena that we saw
at d23 and when folks see it it's gonna
be great people in waiting a long time
for Incredibles to read opposed to the
first one came out in 2004 yeah well
here's the thing about Incredibles like
that's what the Fantastic Four movie
fantastic yeah a lot of people's
favorite Pixar film and this a lot
because family and it's a well-told
superhero film from animation I'm really
surprised it took this long for them to
get back going with it too right I mean
you're gonna give us three cars movies
before you give us a second incredible
movie come on yeah I think we're done
with the cars memories I think we are
too you know we can't go a year without
a Star Wars movie so we're gonna get
solo a Star Wars okay all I just all I
want is for the critics consensus and
the audience consensus to be the same
maybe that's just a person having a
little PTSD in regards to Star Wars
right here's the thing change Directors
midstream what worries me about solo
yeah I was worried about solo long
before well this is the reason why that
is the Star Wars fans sacred cow this is
like Obama's first term like you can't
mess up brah like you've got to make
this perfect if we get a mediocre Han
Solo movie and this already has all the
writing's on the wall that it could be
not from a lack of talent or casting but
just situations Jacqueline I'm not gonna
lie you are scaring me right now this is
the perfect example with with solo they
have all the right ingredients I'm just
worried if anyone remembered to turn on
the oven so where do you guys stand on
Jurassic world fallen Kingdom mmm all
right you know you want to do those the
park Jacqueline wants to close the park
I think it's interesting is that you're
facing a threat against the dinosaurs
where they could once again become
extinct I have zero to no faith that
this movie's gonna be good they put out
that teaser trailer and the negative
chemistry between Bryce and Chris Pratt
just so much showed and it's just I'm
like I don't want to watch another
chemistry vortex it really is it is like
it's like the two magnets that are on
top oh you can just keep pushing away
from each other I so feel I love you
both but mmm here's one I'm excited I'm
glad there's gonna be a sequel to
Pacific Rim because I thought just the
monster kaiju battles in that movie so
much fun
[Music]
I'm interested with this one okay this
one's a blank slate for me I don't know
what it could be
yeah I just wasn't a fan of the first
Pacific Rim real I just it just it just
felt like you know 40 Rock'em Sock'em
robot wasn't that what transformers is
no not bring up those movies one of the
highlights of 2018 is there is not a
transformer that's true that's true
the first transformers is actually
pretty good it was the other four that
suck we're getting a sixth Mission
Impossible they're smart movies yeah
they are smart spy thrillers that have
humor and heart it makes you
disappointed when you see something like
Spectre yeah yeah I have a feeling that
this moves going to reboot the series
just the way that Fast Five rebooted the
Fast and the Furious anyone who was ever
in a fast and furious movie that brought
them all in and they did something a
little different and it reinvigorated
the series oh yeah it just brought like
the paddles to the frame I don't know if
they bring back Paula Patton ready
player one I think we might have entered
earlier but Steven Spielberg is my
favorite director of all time I look at
Spielberg movies the way I look at the
Beatles it's seeing a new Spielberg film
for me is like buying a new Beatles out
and and here's the thing about ready
player one yes the time setting in this
film the 80s video games and all that
stuff it's gonna be nostalgia like candy
for everyone like like other references
it is Chuck it is it is his wheelhouse
yeah because first of all he is a
creationist Allah that he basically
reads book was basically inspired by so
much of what Spielberg produced or
directed yeah yeah I mean I want to live
in a world where ready player one is a
big win for Spielberg oh yeah yeah a
wrinkle in time the only scene
faster than light this is the other one
that's on my list too because I just
love everything that Ava does and
everything that she's created and yeah
Ava Duvernay
and this is the thing with her take on a
wrinkle in time it's like she just lit
she got Oprah I can't get Oprah's number
she's like Oprah come be in my movie and
Oprah said yes and Oprah is like Queen
yes oh I just love that she was able to
do that and I love that she cast storm
read and the lead role Chris Pine had no
intent or want to do that film
his only sole reason for why he wanted
to do wrinkle in time when they asked
him either because she is such a giving
director there needs to be just more
opportunities for women behind the
camera anyway and as we saw in 2017 with
with the patty Jenkins doing Wonder
Woman doesn't matter if you're a man or
a woman if this all is you're a good
director you can make a movie that's
budget over a hundred million dollars I
know you guys had a few personal
favorites that you wanted to bring up
talk to me okay first man this is a
movie about Neil Armstrong yes the Oh
Armstrong has been played by Ryan
Gosling and it is retaining him with his
writer and direct his oscar-winning
director from wile out land now wait is
this gonna be a song and dance on the
moon yes called la la Lander one small
step and one giant fly that's a great
combo I'm looking forward to see ya Ryan
Gosling on the moon all right for me I'm
actually gonna go with a smaller film
that's coming out sorry to bother you
the Stars Tessa Thompson 'la Keith
Stanfield Tessa Thompson played Valkyrie
this year in Thor the Keith Stanfield
wasn't get out he was also in Atlanta so
funny on it land yes oh yeah and then
Armie Hammer who you know just did you
know call me by your name these are some
really great names and it's by boots
Riley he's a record producer and I'm a
lyricist and he comes from like the
Oakland underground hip-hop scene sure
and he wrote this movie is produced by
Forest Whitaker and it's about a guy who
works as a telemarketer who finds a
magical key that allows him to unlock
the system behind his
corporate overlords and it's this
modern-day sci-fi romance slash
adventure movie and I am so here for it
it is so on brand I just cannot wait
that sounds very well yeah and it's
gonna premiere at Sundance it'll
probably be released later on next year
it's got way too many names not to be a
2008 yes that's really yeah yeah I love
just like what you described it's like
it sounds grounded in just accessible
real-life stuff but then wildly
adventurous and an inventive that's cool
what are you most looking forward to
seeing what are you a little bit nervous
about in 2018 let us know in the
comments section below we want to know I
want to thank these awesome movie Minds
for breaking it down
Jacqueline Kohli thank you so much Scott
mance my father my son so I want to
thank you for watching screen junkies
I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on Twitter
bye-bye
[Music]